- [Both] Tweeze those
brows, tweeze those brows.
- [Man] Yeah!
- My girlfriend tweezes my eyebrows,
it's like a weekly thing we do.
I actually find it really therapeutic.
- I've never used one of these.
Usually I'm like, oh what's
this, move that out of the way.
- I don't know how this is done.
- No, this is fleek, though.
- This is, this is, the fleek?
- All right, let's do this.
Cheers, let's go.
- We've got stencils here.
- My eyebrow doesn't
look anything like this.
Oh, this does not look good.
This looks like I need to tweeze
a lot of it.
- Wait, this is bad.
- I may just wing it,
and just do it freehand.
- Brave.
- I'm just gonna grab and pull, like.
- It's what I'm good at.
- [David] Oh, oh.
- Ow, phff, okay.
I mean ...
- I'm getting
some little hairs here.
- This is actually kind of not bad.
- Oh, oh, oh.
Geeze, it hurts.
- Okay, that one hurt.
That was like a bigger hair.
- I don't know what the hell I'm doing.
Just like I don't know what
I'm doing with my life.
- Like, I feel like I'm scared over here.
- Agh!
- Ow.
- Ahhhh.
- Ugh.
- [Indy] Ow, oh.
- All right, here we go.
- Maybe if I start getting
some of these bigger hairs
that are more problematic looking.
- 'kay, all my hairs are
bigger and problematic looking.
Where are your hairs
that you're putting down?
- They're here.
- Look at mine.
You see mine everywhere?
(Chelly laughing)
- Oh damn!
- I don't feel like this is that bad.
- [Indy] Pulling, ow, ow.
- Ah.
- Oh, lord.
- It's getting red.
- Is it?
- Yeah, is that a thing?
- Mm, maybe, I dunno.
- No stop, stop, stop.
- Agh!
- This is actually starting
to look pretty solid.
- This is, I think I'm
starting to look good.
- Yeah, it actually is.
- Right?
- Your arch game on point.
- I do feel a little more glamorous.
- I have two brows now.
- Oh yeah.
- Pretty good.
- Look, it looks like I've done
literally nothing, and look.
(David chuckling)
This is absurd.
Oh, I do have a tiny arch, like real tiny.
- It's 'cause you're making it, man.
You make your arch.
- This wasn't that painful.
I think if guys are scared, or
anyone's scared of the pain,
it's really, like, negligible.
- Yeah, I don't think I'm
gonna tweeze my eyebrows again.
I mean, at least by myself.
- Take your hairs and throw
it in the air (laughing).
- Like confetti?
- Yeah (laughing) mine
could be like confetti.
- It's too much.
- Dude, look at this.
- Oh, that's too much, that's gross.
- Here's all my, anybody want my DNA?
Oh wow, it came all the way...
- It's, yeah,
you got lots.
- It's everywhere.
- I mean, I got hairs too.
- Guys, if you need some Chelly DNA, yeah.
(upbeat music)
(soft whooshing)
(metal creaking)